ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
athletes of the olympic window games
after a troubled build-up the 24th
winter olympics have officially begun in
beijing the venue for friday's opening
ceremony was the bird's nest stadium
originally built for the summer olympics
back in 2008. it's the first city ever
to host both the winter and summer games
like the tokyo olympics last year kobit
19 has given these games a different
complexion they're taking place inside a
closed loop system keeping competitors
and staff away from the general public
athletes must get tested for covert 19
daily and there are no foreign fans with
only a small hand-picked domestic
audience allowed to attend
some of the world's best winter athletes
are unable to compete after testing
positive this is much tougher than
injury because you aren't putting
yourself out there to take the risk it's
just the risk is everywhere around us
and i really feel for those athletes i
can't i can't even imagine how it must
be to do four years of work and then at
the last minute to have that taken away
by something that's out of your control
several world leaders have traveled to
beijing for the games but other nations
including the us britain and canada have
declared a diplomatic boycott over
china's human rights record specifically
its treatment of muslim uighurs china
denies human rights abuses the people's
republic of china is perpetrating a
campaign of gross human rights
violations including genocide
over the next two weeks is our urgent
moral duty
to shine a bright light on the many
human rights violations being
perpetrated by the host nation
beijing 2022 organizers say the games
will be carbon neutral all venues will
be powered by renewable energy and five
of them have been repurposed from 2008
but with very little snowfall more than
200 million litres of water have been
used to generate fake powder for the
alpine locations
let's not be naive you know artificial
snow is used
in in i mean a consistent way for
decades you know in a winter competitive
sport what is really important like for
any other activities
that
we we practice is to try to do it in the
most efficient way
with the lead up to the olympics
dominated by politics and covert 19 most
of the athletes will hope the focus now
shifts to the action as nearly 3 000
competitors from 91 nations fight to
take home a gold medal david stokes al
jazeera